well thank you it is great to see
everybody here thank you to make America
again for letting us come and be here in
this venue pie de de started about three
years ago in 2012 a tiny little
gathering of folks like-minded folks
trying to basically make Python better
and really get to a point we could start
saying things like this like python is a
Zen of data science a little bit bold a
little bit i'll talk a little bit why i
think that's the case but i really am
grateful for the organizers and those
who have been here i want to reiterate
jeff's words that's a lot of
behind-the-scenes work that goes on i'm
able to see a lot of it not all of it
and it humbles me to see how much effort
goes into that the work here it also
humbles me to see how much effort goes
into the tools and the progress they're
making rapidly and it's very exciting to
see my co-founder Peter Wang is he's on
his way he was a very ill so I'm
impressed he's going to come out here
I'll likely give the talk even though he
helped me prepare it and there's a lot
of ideas those you have seen us both
talk we'll see so definitely some of the
influence of a beater weighing in the
words today so it's great to be here so
I want to talk today about data science
and how high how Python could be
considered the Zen of data science and
move on to kind of some of the tools
that we're working on and how they can
help us keeping farther along with Zen
so data science that Phillips smart
stark best herb chair of statistics
University of Berkeley looks like our
slides are cut off at the bottom
unfortunately i'm not sure what the
rendering here is ok up the what if we
can fix that actually maybe we can't so
i'll have to just make sure that some of
the things we get cut off at the bottom
unfortunately the slides will be online
later so you can take a look at them but
the point about data science it actually
connects three different they at least
three different things in this
particular framing gives us an
interesting way to look at it because
the insights come by the intersection of
all three of these things subject matter
expertise critical thinking and applied
statistics access to tools if you kind
of miss one and you get things like you
know incorrect conclusions if you just
have the subject matter expertise and
access to tools we don't have critical
thinking or apply statistics or you get
inability to deliver or execute if you
don't have access to tools we've all
probably seen in our liar
our work some aspect of centering in
some of these spaces and insights kind
of become in the beginning in the middle
of that and so really we're talking to
cut up about if we're going to say
python is the Zen of data science well
first a little history about Zen like
what is what is then zen instead of just
being a marketing ploy to sell oriental
books and novels Zen actually does is a
is a religious tradition and from that
from the east Buddhism was about a lot
of sutras a lot of doctrines it had
their so here's a eighty thousand texts
in one house location in the Far East
kind of showing all the rules and the
doctrines surrounding that one group of
peeps collars put together for Buddhism
and really an influence also by tau tau
isms and really is about finding the
core finding the root finding the find
the essence of something focusing on the
thing rather than all the details the
doctrines the the accoutrements around
it so what are the what are the things
one one metaphor is if Zen is the moon
all the things or our fingers pointing
to the moon so if the Zen is the thing
you're actually after so it can be
categorized as the Zen approach and this
comes from zen mine beginner's mind
there's an approach about the right
practice the right attitude the right
understanding the Zen way of calligraphy
for examples to write in the most
straightforward simple way is if you're
a beginner now trying to make something
skill for a beautiful but simply riding
with the full attention as if you're
discovering what you're writing for the
first time so those are you familiar
with Python can kind of see yourselves
at the in a Jupiter notebook or at the
command line trying to explore and
understand your data make a connection
with it and discover the data around you
instead of just you have tried to build
a system then hopefully land on it
sometime later the right understanding
let's dig a little deeper here you know
one articulation of Zen is the you know
is somebody who quotes a the purpose of
studying Buddhism is not to study
Buddhism but a study ourselves you are
not your body it's not it's if you are
not your body and Python you could got
to make a similar claim the purpose of
writing python code not just to produce
software but to study ourselves you are
not your technology stack
so you can actually think of the
pythonic approach to data science you
compose here just an attempt at
describing that could pythonic approach
choose language primitives built-ins
classes wherever possible don't try to
invent your own object stack of you
don't need to choose the language
primitives much more powerful and
accessible than trying to memorize a
huge list of proprietary functions we
reject artificial distinctions but where
data should live and where it gets
computed empower every individual to use
their own knowledge instead of taking
the design power of their hands with
preordained architectures and stacks
really about and then be a wide Python
will get a little deeper into the kind
of the pythonic approach to data science
and what Botanic data analysis looks
like and how that could be considered
Zen why Python let's start there by then
it has grown into a powerful tool for
data analysis really because of its
roots as a teaching language I believe
because it's accessible to a lot of a
large group of people many people
confuse Python actually see a lot of
literature a lot of lot of tech writers
they'll often talk about Python and
they'll focus on one of these stacks
kind of one of these angles only a lot
of folks will put books on Python
programmers and they'll think oh Python
the language and a look at books the
people writing the developers are using
and they'll miss a whole class of users
who aren't developers never categorize
themselves developers but are using
Python nonetheless those are the people
that are usually here or come into a
sci-fi conference or try to understand
the Python is a tool for data analysis
and in the in the middle we have kind of
tool builders I've always considered
myself to kind of be right in the middle
there I've become more of a programmer
over the years but I have started square
in the middle as a scientist programmer
usually build simple things just patient
many cases just had the had the patient
to pull a bunch of net lib fortran code
and wrap them into python and put it out
to the web then what wasn't really a
brilliant work was a lot of tedious work
but it was just sort of this needs to be
there as either exist I'm going to do it
and Python makes it easy and accessible
to me and when others to have that power
as well but with richness behind it
analysts even all the way up to people
who don't code hardly at all they cut
and paste it's cut and paste programmers
they get paid for the inside they just
want to be able to call functions stick
a few things together have a little bit
of extensibility and don't take that
away
and hide it behind just a simple graph
or a big red salt button how the ability
to do some change have the ability to
program a little bit a certain way
Python supports all of these use cases
and so when you go to a Python when you
think about Python it's actually an it's
not just a community it's a society it's
an ecosystem there isn't just one group
of people in it and not going to be
confusing actually the newcomers because
you go and you talk to somebody go will
ok which Python tribe are you actually
because it's there's different tribes
even inside of data science and
scientific computing there's folks that
know I'm a data scientist no no I'm a
computational scientist no I'm a Pam
disz user on a numpy user even though
they're all kind of mix and or
unorganized with each other there's a
lot of folks in our Python ecosystem
which i think is important because there
are a lot of people in the world and so
if you think about getting at the root
of computing you do or you are going to
get to the root of people and you have
to have something that's accessible to a
large number of people that can be
approached by many of them so I think
again more about pythonic data analysis
one of the key things I believe in a
mistake often made particular data
analysis is the you want to connect
people with the data as soon as possible
the first step in data analysis not go
by a big system and hope somebody uses
it it's not just more hardware and more
data there's been a lot of push a lot of
promotion around just go get all the
data store it there then you can be like
Google because they start all their data
now they're doing a lot of cool things
so if you did that maybe you lose some
cool things too well there's a few steps
between here and there and storing your
data just somewhere you can all give it
you can just hopefully use it in some
sense people have been doing that for a
long time they just called it Oracle or
they call it sequel server they called
it they put their data somewhere in a
database the problem is always
accessibility it's about connecting the
people that know what to do with the
data and make it available to them and
that's really what Python excels at
actually Python excels it's the agility
of connecting people to their date on
their models that's really what the PI
data stack means there's a great essay
by Guido that I read when I was a
younger person against this beard here
is to kind of indicate that an older
person now
no when I was a younger person I
remember reading Guido talked about
Python and about connecting with your
code making mistakes quickly staying
connected talk to Raymond heninger he's
a great teacher of Python and he talks
constantly about staying in connected
with your data and making progress
against your code by just reading your
data always being connected with what
you're doing and what you're trying to
do next rather than kind of starry-eyed
dream about what you might do then hope
it works in production somehow when you
apply it to a big to a big data lake
right there's a lot of disconnects
happening today because of that Python
can help but it's tricky there's some
real challenges too because the
immediate connection usually comes
within memory usually because it's in
memory you can do it immediately there's
an immediate response and going to scale
usually means give you more computers
involved and that has latency
implications that has delay it has
latency implications that has
implications on things some things that
you do easily in memory don't really
paralyzed very well and scale certain
operations things like sorting things
like shuffling data around it doesn't
work so well at thousands of nodes when
your data exists all over the place and
have to be a cross shuffle across
everything that works just fine we was
thinking about a single memory stack but
PI data means agility let the data drive
the analysis not the technology stack
that's that's a hope that's a dream
that's what we're working for it's a lot
of people are working for right now the
technology stack is still driving a lot
of our analysis like here's your stairs
your stack here's your cluster here's
what you can do okay now here's your
window you can look up your data with
but well that's okay I don't know how to
look through that window that's what I
want to do I'm a here's understeers the
concepts I want to understand I don't
have to up to mentally map that to
something else let the data drive not
usually means the data scientists the
data analysts need to drive that the
decision the technology stack one great
thing about python is that it has this
notion you talk to a lot of scientists
i've asked him over the years why do you
use python why why have you chosen
python wondering about python 2011 peter
and i noticed at the strata conference
with a lot of big data vendors is there
was nobody on the floor of the boot of
the event floor of selling anything that
even talked about python it was all
everything else you go to
talks at least half of the talks people
were using Python so there's nobody
promoting it but it had been selected by
the people than spied by people who had
been using it so I was a really
important observation and I felt like I
was one of those people kind of in the
middle in the trenches and so that's why
we started continuum really it was to
just support that kind of help those
folks in the the wind the the wind of
other technologies that are being
promoted and coordinate with those
technologies where possible but I've
asked lots of scientists why Python and
they met and they said it fits my brain
it gets out of my way is another way to
kind of a corollary of that I not to
think about the language I think about
my I'm doing rather than getting stuck
in you know which concept am I using
having to learn a whole lot of other
kinds of ideas scale outs a later step
it's an important step and Python can
work with you there to their great duels
no matter where your data stored or how
it's stored or or what you how your
cluster is managed not tied to a
particular distributed story that's a
great thing about python is it it's a
hetero G its heterogeneity genius it's a
glue for you everywhere so of course if
I'm talking about python is the Zen of
data science have to talk about the zens
inside of Python itself so this is
really tiny because you're not going to
read it here this is go in port this at
your prompt and you can get the full
beauty of the xana python i will just
select one because it was a mistake i
made as a young inexperienced well it
should have been more experienced but i
was maybe in a hurry developer trying to
make it to get numpy out the door in the
face of ambiguity refuse the temptation
to guess right there's a few things
inside of numpy that are actually
they're really bad actually there's
there's only a couple things actually
most of it I'm pretty proud of there's a
few places where it's like that really
really sucked and and really it can be
driven down to making a mistake here of
refusing not I didn't refuse a
temptation to guess a guest and guest
badly so because there's ambiguity just
don't do it there's a lot of other
nuggets of wisdom here a few years ago I
put this list together as Emma numpy
I'll put in parenthesis and pandas maybe
we're
Jeff to kind of organize an actual zenit
pandas but there's some ideas here that
are common to both both systems
Australia's better than scattered I'll
just point a ray oriented data orient is
often better than object oriented one of
the challenges I see in data today is
people they want to build objects and
that's great for mental modeling about
your thoughts but when you try to put in
production a bunch of objects scattered
all throughout history it really makes
it difficult you see this concept today
also serve as seen in an ocean of
column-oriented everything I think guys
we column-oriented it's like yes welcome
to the 40s welcome to the 60s like yes
exactly right that's what array
computing is all about that's why it
wasn't focused on it why you PL existed
why numpy existed and people who have
been using numpy and pandas have
recognized that for a long time and it's
great to see that energy start to
actually make traction in the broader
world split apply combine and you
vectorize is awesome i'll put here
you'll write more you function
generalize you funks those you don't
know how to do that with numba you're
missing out on a huge opportunity I
noticed that I probably haven't promoted
that enough because it is extremely
powerful and mostly if you're using
pandas are using numpy you're not you
don't know what a how to let number
build you a generalized you funk you
have a problem because you're missing
out a lot of potential power that you're
not taking advantage of so I'll just say
more later about that and then here's my
attempt it's very you know one point oh
maybe python is the Santa data science
you know is it did big disclaimer will
probably revamp this is what I they call
the crapple license but this is released
under the crapple CRA PL license which
means basically so it's it's just barely
started and you can get use of you want
and get rid of it if you don't want get
more and better data be the first start
data data needs to drive the
conversation and just after that is
better data how do you know it's how you
got better data well it's better models
you don't know if you have a better date
unless you have a model about the data
so get better models to get there more
and better data more in better models
how you compute matters especially today
where you have a increasing divergence
between the ideal compute and the actual
compute you see a lot of energy going
into a multi-core and GPU
array computing is a lot easier today
than to take a bunch of little
individual processors and try to do
things distributed with a bunch of
little things orders of magnitude 3 or 4
5 34 at least am sometimes even five
orders of magnitude speed differences
that can make a huge difference you're
trying to get something done I can I've
seen it in production at places make a
difference between people tearing their
hair out not going to houma weekends and
be able to actually go home because it
takes 24 hours to do something to takes
20 minutes to do something so they can
actually iterate more quickly that's
where computation time matters
tremendously is if it interferes their
ability to be agile if you can if you
can't fail quickly tell quickly and
often but not in the same way right you
know how to keep doing the same thing
over and over again but you do need to
it to iterate and be agile means you've
you're failing essentially so if aliens
is not a dirty word it's a good thing if
you're learning from unable to it
quickly put the data in the hands and
minds of people with knowledge where and
how the data is stored is secondary to
analysis and understanding that's not
typically what a lot of money is being
spent to try to convince you otherwise
basically but it's catching up people
are recognizing that the only way to use
the data you're storing so greatly is to
actually put an allison or standing and
tools for those folks in the hand in
their hands this is a little bit
controversial perhaps without you know
premature horizontal scaling with
apologies to knuth premature horizontal
scaling is root of all evil look at that
broader text I'm referencing the
premature optimizations root of all evil
if you look at his brother statement he
says actually optimization is necessary
at times so that's why I'm partly using
that is because horizontal scaling isn't
necessary at times but let's not it's
not necessary a lot of times a lot of
times just solve the problem first
understand what you're doing first then
talked about how to scale it that when
you must scale data locality parallel
algorithms are the key and you have to
learn to think in the building blocks
that can be paralyzed and not take some
time that's that's the key they'll take
some time so I want to spend the last
few the last time part of my talk
talking about how the PI data stack that
exists and some of the tools we're using
a continuum to kind of help Python
continue to be a better than of data
science there's about three million
users the PI data stack don't I mean you
can quote me on that I guess but I don't
I mean it's it's it's intentionally like
only one cinnamon figure I don't really
know how many there are but I it's
roughly it's at least in that in that
category and on top of numpy of course a
rich set of tools CyHi pandas matplotlib
second image task models and
scikit-learn and the Jupiter stack and
lots of a strip I opencv there's a
tremendous number of other tools and
that's the power of the Python system
actually it's great to be a Python user
right i mean it's it's sort of if you're
a Python user you think i have this
interesting problem to solve and it's
not just necessarily a data science
problem but maybe it's a data gluing or
a data engineering problem and you look
around you see oh there's some of you
already thought about this and did
something in that direction so it's
going to be very very powerful one of
the challenges though in that space when
we start a continuum is okay awesome i
just have now a thousand packages that I
want to use how to actually deliver that
reliably in a way that isn't just okay
I've got I've got that delivered but
5,000 people my organization each have
delivered it differently slightly
different changes and they're all using
kind of their own integration systems we
started with continuing with three goals
scaled a numpy Paideia stack
horizontally you know take the numbers
of pi data dump I pandas and make it
scale horizontally give the ability to
do that make it easy for Python users to
produce data science applications in
their browser and click with visit with
heavy visualization and get more
adoption of the PI data stack those are
really our goals so we didn't think
about putting out a distribution in
Python we first started but very quickly
it was realized okay we have a lot of
things you're trying to ship we got to
figure out a way to ship that really
easily so we wrote a package manager
Conda and then a distribution of Python
and our turns out we can ship are the
same way we're shipping Python and we
call that anaconda anaconda is in my
mind really is a game-changing
enterprise-ready python distribution
it's bsd licensed with our new anna
konno subscriptions we've recently made
anaconda itself the core bsd license so
you can use it distribute it put it
wherever you like you know tell us about
if you like but don't if you don't want
to just use it and
particularly use the ability of the
condo house to quickly make easy micro
containers there's a lot of users of
your not alone if using a condo there's
at least you know we don't know how many
users of anaconda exactly but they're 12
million downloads last two years 200k a
month and growing five million packages
per month are served by the condo
package manager from just our
repositories of course anybody can make
a repository and serve packages from
them so it's certainly not tracking all
of the potential users there are a lot
of users and some of you this is users
of the Anaconda stack certainly not all
of them but there's certainly a lot of
them a lot of people are able to use
these tools so what does that it kind of
provide you if you haven't heard of it
you're not using it try it out it really
provides one way to describe it is
portable user level environments easy to
install quick and agile data exploration
it really adds the agility to not just
the coding that I'm doing but the
deployment that I'm doing so I can try
some stuff out I can be in my stack and
I can go there's a common story people
were scared I've literally talked to
people one of the folks just started
with us he was scared to use anaconda
because he was scared to touch his
Python distribution and I had to just
smile at him because I understood how he
felt I did like I spent two weeks
getting this Python installation working
for me I can't change it and I know
that's how it used to be I understand I
feel your pain but I you know it was
awesome when I could just delete my
python isolation I didn't care because I
can get it back in like two seconds and
I can do that over and over and over
again I can have a hundred different
Python distribution or installations on
one machine or on a box of machines easy
easy to use and that's what Conda is
brought to the community it's simple to
collaborate you can specify your
environment you can specify your
requirements ship them and reproduce
something exactly as you want it and
it's accessible to all I'll say about
how anaconda solves kind of a big
picture problem with traditional
analytics that may not be obvious at
first glance but it's related to pop
come python is the data is the Zen of
data science traditional holodecks you
have your data here you have an ETL
process we extract transform load the
data pull from the data to something and
from there you can do data mining or
modeling and usually these are sep
by wide chasms and large systems and a
lot of expense and then on top of the
data mining or modeling you'll have some
usage some bi reports and maybe a
production application to play a
deployed application in production and
it kind of really can sit on top of all
of that and make those chasms like a
bridge over all those chasms all that of
course when I say onaconda those
in-the-know here understand that it's
really the tools of the PI data stack
and allowing you just to connect all the
different things are available and make
them accessible to the data to the user
so that you can be driven completely by
your data you basically put in the hands
of your data scientists and your experts
driving the reports all that medial
middle ground that's Patricia leaden
dominated by fiefdom xande people who
own different things you can actually
just bypass a lot of it and help connect
the people together I'm going to skip
over the features of Conda if you don't
know about Conda some of you are
anaconda users don't know about Conda
you're missing out you're missing a
really capable feature set that could be
helping you helping you try new things
out helping you development helping you
in production help you deploy things
it's got absolutely excellent support
for system-level environments it's like
having many VMS with much lighter weight
we sometimes call the micro containers
or the undock or you can sit on top of
dr but you really want to be able to
have a slim pool application with a lot
of dependencies Connor can manage all of
those very easily and reproduce you very
quickly it's a very simple format so
anybody can produce a kind of package
there are tools standard tools to build
them but you can make one pretty easily
tarball with some metadata it's easy to
create multiple channels you can make a
real and repository with a conta index
command on an HTML served set of files
and integrates very well with Pip and
other language platform package managers
like em PM&R and ours see ran install
commands so there's the basic commands
these will be available on the slides
later there's even advanced counter
usage and the documentation there's
actually some cheat sheets out on our
death table if you want so probably
sport of the better things to grab if
you if you leave here and you know
environments are a big deal environments
are implemented efficiently on windows
mac and linux with hard links and soft
links or copies if necessary but only if
necessary so you can have gigabytes of
packages and only only copy them if you
need to if it's the same environment you
just kind of
and so you're sharing lots of the same
set of cache data across many many
environments and some of you may know
about anaconda cloud we're really
encouraging folks to sign up for an
account of cloud it's free but it's a
place you can store if you if you know
you could just build a kind of index on
top of any repository you like but if
you don't want to do that effort you
just want to have a package you want to
ship to the world and have already see
you can upload a time it kind of cloud
and will host it for you as long as it's
publicly available it's free but if you
want to kind of only limit it to a
certain few people then you do have to
sign up for a subscription but publicly
available is free that same system and
technology is actually available to put
behind your repository if you're a
commercial location where you want to
have private on-premises features it's
all available you can install the things
you see an anaconda cloud behind your
firewall I want to talk a little bit
about anaconda cluster because i think
it's an underappreciated thing not many
people know about it it's basically one
key tool it is only available for
subscribers you can use it for free on
four nodes anywhere and on 16 nodes on
cloud systems you know a juror and AWS
or you can do the license and use it
behind your firewall for as many as you
like but it helps you basically robustly
manage a runtime state on all your nodes
in a cluster so you can now bring the
power of anaconda easily to everything
and interact with Hadoop the tube system
like spark here's a quick way to build a
spark cluster with a simple profile and
create it submit a job to it destroy it
very very easily many people who we've
have used this system it's like it's the
fastest way to set up spark they've seen
so it's very very simple to get started
with the cluster know the cluster tools
are used to you can manage on a career
cluster manage those environments that
are available in each cluster and you
can easily remote send arbitrary
commands to every node in the cluster
and here's an example with a spark
command a lot of people using pi spark
that's great it's a good start we do
have some higher level approaches that
we're encouraging to integrate python to
what i consider me more pythonic
approaches PI spark is is useful but you
want to be able to have approach that
will scale out not just a spark with any
other system Impala that comes down the
down
pipe here's a quick way though to
basically do a simple job that uses a
spark context all right I want to spend
a little bit of time talking to kind of
about Continuum's approach to some of
these problems basically thinking about
making Python the Zen of data science
and continuing that effort blaze has
been our project it's a big project and
it's turned into an ecosystem start as
kind of a next-generation numpy pandas
which is really said as a as a rallying
cry to get people who are interested in
the same concept to join us in that
effort there was some funding a proud
that we used from some sources to help
promote it but it really is an
infrastructure for metadata meta compute
and expression graphs and workflows it's
a it's it's still emerging and it's
actually made a lot of progress and it's
even usable there there's multiple
products inside the ecosystem that are
extremely usable and then blaze library
is also usable today although it's it's
refocusing and is still I would consider
to be the blaze library is still I would
consider to be beta where so if you're
using it work with us coordinate with us
because we're working we're still making
it what we need it to be but blaze
really the whole concept of blaze is
really glue two point oh it's to you
know pythons legacy is a powerful glue
language to me to play files called fast
libraries integrate things disparate
things the next generation glue needs to
integrate disparate compute silos data
silos disjoint memory and compute
runtimes transcend legacy models on
computers make it so that you can write
an expression one of the things one of
its goals is to eliminate the problem
today of when you have a data query and
a data science problem your first
question is where's the data stored how
is it stored you have to answer that
question because that answer that
question drives how you write your
analysis it's very similar the days of
our legacy days in the 60s where you
have different kinds of machines you got
to compute problem you said what's
machine are you on because I have to
write my assembly differently right and
we didn't have see you didn't have
fortran in fact 4chan was written to
solve that problem and give people a
common way to write expressions that
weren't on run mobile machines we kind
of backed the same problem a little bit
because we have different machines
different systems sequel also was
written for that purpose as well to
write different databases the same same
language Blaze's insight is in some
sense
the sequel of Python for data science
for big data lets you write data rate
write expressions in one language and
have multiple backends that actually
support it give you an opportunity to do
some optimizations here's a little slide
deck that kind of explains blaze Peter
Wang put these together I'll hopefully
do them justice if he actually he joined
us in the back so maybe you can come up
and if you have real questions you can
ask him but he can't talk oh he's sick
that's right thank you sorry Peter I
won't put you on the spot but but you
know in the beginning we have data and
we have epic anemia brains actually well
in the Far beginning brains emerged then
we have brains trying to understand data
so pencil and paper math you know did
some cool stuff the gal you know Galileo
galaxies guys are pretty smart and doing
some math the math gets the data gets
bigger the math gets harder we scratch
our head trying to figure out what to do
so we build computers and we have
computers doing the math for us okay
that's great but we still know what the
computer should do now they're just look
where's the brain do now there's a brain
s talk the computer and make programs
now so we select reg ex right we have we
have one problem to solve another
problem now we have three problems so
now what do I do so talk how two brains
talk two computers how do I do that well
basically emerge different systems to do
different things so you'd have an HTML
system to run away be able web page what
you do to build a web page but it's what
you do to build a sequel engine versus
what you do to build a general program
or a game like minecraft is quite
different and we call that you know
general-purpose programming so the
computer does all these different things
general-purpose programming turns out to
be kind of hard actually that's why we
have computer science as a degree field
and people kind of learn how to do
general-purpose programming and the data
scientists the people actually on to
analysis kind of go okay yeah that's
great I don't want to become a Java
expert or a C++ expert I want to go to
my data science so we build analytic
systems people have built the main Civic
languages doing speed query languages
sequel matlab our spss SAS these are
domain civic query languages and an
analytic systems and you basically have
parallel kinds of systems for building
web pages HTML CSS
general Java CPP C++ Hall computer
science to build games so blaze is
really about okay can we do something
about this a little bit how do we how do
we take the brain the compute the data
join them together a little bit more
robustly a little more easily so we can
mix and match so if you think of the the
brain is really about expressions it's
what the person wants to do kind of a
high-level expression approach sequel is
an example expressions and then the
runtime so those the runtime could be
numpy pandas are could be Julia sequel
spark [ __ ] Cassandra run to HTML system
it's basically the computer runtime
compute then we have the data which is
you know what kind of data is it what
metadata surrounds that which is what
schema does it have the distributor what
kind of data type is that what's the
data sheet is hdf5 with formats it in
the expressions or operations group buys
filters so these sort of this is what
the blaze ecosystem is designed to
really help us get a handle on allow us
to separate talking about these concepts
so that we can talk about them
separately and bring them together in a
runtime at the last kind of the final
moment as late as possible rather than
joining them together at the hip
starting off the gate when you can't you
can't change anything once you've joined
things together you're sort of stuck you
can't refactor so that's the whole
purpose is to make code reusable make
people able to connect to lots of
runtime lots of data that's really the
idea blaze and blaze the library itself
sits the expression level then we have a
lot of runtime task which talk about
later is actually a new runtime concept
paralyzing runtime for Python and that's
all about the computes where numpy where
pandas where those runtime systems live
then data shape is really a metadata
description to talk about data all kinds
of data that you might want to do
something with then odo is a tool to
basically go back and forward tween lots
of the latest shapes also different kind
of data containers that's really the
idea blaze so if we talk about the
expression level what does blaze do it's
an interface to query on different
storage systems when we describe it so
you can have a blaze expression back-end
to spark or come back into Impala or
come back into numpy Ord ask you can
back it that question of what it back
ends to can be answered later you don't
have to
it helps you avoid the technology stack
debt oh I made that choice to use this
particular technology stack so now I
can't chip from it because it's got on
my code written in it so write your code
at a higher level it's the same the same
really problem the sequel help solve
with the same caveats in terms of you
know we want to have performance you
want to make sure we get the best
optimizations possible here's an example
of the kinds of systems are supported s3
MongoDB JSON sequel CSV obviously the
kinds of computation you can do on each
those data systems will vary our focus
at continuum well first of all it's
whatever our customers want so if you
get a client that will pay us we will
actually happily focus on whatever you'd
like so there is a way to nerd swipe our
brilliant nerds however if we're doing
things on our road map we we focus on
the idea of dark data in the PI data
stack we want to take the PI data stack
and enable it to handle all just all
kinds of tribute of data so you look at
our task project we have a distributed
thing so and then having blaze itself
work really really well on that back-end
really taking you can imagine taking out
of Conda and making anaconda into a
basically distributed database runtime
on top of any data so kind of taking all
of your data out there dark data really
is what describes your files that nobody
puts in databases that's you're using
all the time so excel files CSV files
hdf5 files just stuff this showing up
everywhere but you got to get a handle
on it and then be able to do analytics
on it and anaconda can basically that
database runtime engine you can stick
near all of those data points and give
yourself essentially a ad hoc database
on top of everything blaze already has
features for selecting columns filtering
operating reducing split apply combine
and what blaze does is translate those
expressions to basic different backends
including sequel backends including desk
back ends at the heart of blaze is a
data shaped concept it extends the
d-type concept in numpy if I had more
time I go into more detail about d-type
and how I think d-type is one of the
core things out of numpy that should be
factored into the Python ecosystem
generally and talk more about that if
somebody's interested data shape is a
very straightforward extension of the
d-type but it basically combines
dimension indy type that gives rise to
the ability to handle
variable-length arrays as well as ragged
arrays you can connect the two together
so you can have a VAR of in 32 that's a
variable-length array of in 32 s you can
have a string you can have float64 is
you have missing data types here's a
series of examples arrays of structures
structure of arrays are all supported by
the data shaped concept just regular
arrays and then structures and all kinds
of detailed the ? means missing data
needs optional data and dying which the
library we haven't talked about dying as
a C++ library also in beta still a beta
product so the beta library alpha
library it supports the data shaped
protocol so you basically can do numpy
like activities on optional data with
dined blade server is one of the things
I'm excited really excited about because
it presents you can stick a place server
next year data and it presents that data
in a in a way that you can compute on
that other systems can understand it use
it deal with it and you can though those
become basically abstract tables
available in a system for another
another computer in the system so and
there's there's more work coming down
the pipe over the next six months on
that here's an example of the blade
server from blaze import data you stick
data alone now there's a blaze URI so of
course the blade server what it does it
maps all the other kinds of you are eyes
you might have as three sequel I'd kind
of abstract those into a single name so
anything else you have whether it's a
gfs file or a series of data in any data
system is now accessible as a blaze URI
URL and you can then look at it see it
you're not God you've got a piece of the
data then you write compute on it not
compute can get sent to where the data
needs to get sent in order to run the
system so compute recipes work with
existing libraries at multiple backends
so with basically numpy and pandas like
syntax you can run on top of sparker and
Paula or [ __ ] or and ask as we're
seeing so ideally layer expressions of
ernie data but i want to talk so blazed
the high level and we're still working
pretty hard on making that high level
make the current roadmap for blaze is
making consistency between blaze arrays
and between desk between desk as we'll
talk about and pandas and numpy making
sure you can go seamlessly from
numpy pandas expressions now I want to
make see if that scales blaze the whole
point is to make sure only things that
scale are included in it so it when you
translate your numpy code to your blaze
code you'll know that it's scales
basically your pan this code your blades
code all the stuff that doesn't scale is
not available you kind of recognize oh
that must not scale because it's not
available right that's the idea so you
can understand better how to move from
interactive agile on a single machine to
scale out on multimer scenes so it start
doc is actually a it's lower down the
stack plays a very high level and the
intent is for very occasional developers
only so to speak task is a library that
is really parallel numpy parallel data
frames parallel pandas it's a little
more for the acute the developer wants
to go there hands of a dirty you have to
understand things a little bit more it's
general fine-grained ad-hoc parallelism
it's a parallel computing framework it
leverages the excellent Python ecosystem
it's a fairly straightforward adoption
it uses blocked algorithms and task
scheduling written in pure python so
it's easy to install easy to put
anywhere you want it the core idea is
behind desk or the dynamic task
scheduling yield same parallelism
essentially what you're doing with
making parallelism is task scheduling
and understanding the different things
you want to do and breaking those apart
it's a sim this is a very simple library
to enable parallelism that's been proven
out as a lot of people have been able to
adapt dash to there were use cases so
the x-ray projects able to use dass get
out of core and the arrays labeled
arrays I think pandas has a not has a
presence is it really in the release yet
or is it actually just in master its
kind of experimenting with a two
parallel command he's I've seen some
code so I don't know where it is it
might still be in Jeff's Jeff's single
box though experiment with the idea of
can you take you know how easy is it to
help somebody go from there domain to a
parallel it's not a big bulky thing to
adapt so I could learn folks have been
able to use gas to enable certain kinds
of grid searching certain kinds of
embarrassingly parallel searches
parameter sweeps for the partial fit
capability and scikit-learn has been
able to adopt ask so dass got a lot of
input from a lot of folks very quickly
because it's very simple it's a very
straightforward idea
then you have desk arrays and das data
frames which just encapsulate the
function the functionality and then one
of the keys of Dallas has always been
that we started with a multi with an out
of core system it's a distributed
scheduler to make the work go easily so
classic example in ocean temperature
data this is fine you know if you have
just have a 720 x 4 40 array each day
every 4th degree we're used to dealing
with that it's finally do average global
ocean temperature data in 2015 with this
simple mean calculation okay that's
awesome now if we have 36 years of that
and you don't have that much RAM you're
not at a place I have been places people
have three terabytes of RAM so they
would look at this so yeah I have that
Ram no problem I'll just still type me
but even if you do have that much RAM
you may not be using your cores
reliability here very well and you want
to actually take advantage of multiple
cores so task is still useful because it
makes it easy for you to block up the
different computations and run them on
different cores so a block mean
calculation is what you want to do so
you got a better start chunking so what
doused array does does is it really just
does that chunking does an automatic
chunking of your array and so that any
time you do an operation then it maps
meet calculations like mean calculations
like sums on to graph calculations oh I
have to do this on these different
things in the nice something I add the
results back together that's basically a
task array is is building these graphs
so the whole concept of das can be
summarized in this slide where you have
at the center of these graphs these
distributed these directed graphs a
cyclic graphs of calculations you'd be
computed you have schedulers on the
right there's a synchronous schedule
which is basically just test this make
sure it works make sure I get the same
result as a numpy maybe I don't have
some problem in my threading then there
are threaded and multiprocessing those
are a single machine out of core
solutions so I can have multiple threads
which works actually even if using
Python code because those of you who've
moved to PI data stack know that a lot
of a pirate stack releases the gill
think pan has just joined that in mini
that that fold but numpy has for a long
time lots of sci-fi does pandas does so
they release the gill when they're
executing the low-level seat code so you
can multi threading does work and the PI
data stack pretty well and you get
multiple core behavior so you have to
always tongue-in-cheek in a little bit
when people talk about oh pythons cabby
it's not paralyzed well the Regals never
released and the answer is yes if you're
always just writing Python interpreter
code but the PI data stack actually does
a lot of Python interpreter steering a
lot of native code and the native coke
and run will put the multi-core just
fine number which I won't get time to
talk about eat makes it easy to release
the gill on your compiled Python code
and then the collections are things like
arrays and data frames they're
high-level things that lets you just use
your simple expressions you're used to
and it builds these graphs for you then
you have a lot of schedulers beneath the
distributive schedule is something I'm
excited about there's that's just
starting to come into play and over the
next several months we'll make will make
rapid progress so there's the is a
simple architecture for scaling here's
examples of using desk or AIDS the
interface is just like numpy raised
except you have a chunk parameter if you
really if you want to it there's a
default chunking that'll do if you want
to specify you can and then you can
basically do our calculations just like
you do on an umpire ray except instead
of giving you an actual result it gives
back a a thing that needs to be computed
basically gives you back a value ated
result and if the result doesn't fit
into memory you can then put a day cf5
and compute the result that way so dass
Garre and doused data frame are two
interfaces to the system that both of
these build directed graphs of
calculations have to be computed and
then a problem of a computing those can
be separated out into our medieval
multi-core I mean do multiple machines
how many marriages distributed
computation so it's a really nice simple
system that can be applied to and it's a
pythonic approach I would say to the
problem of parallelization and you know
it learns from a lot of the tools are
out there already here's more complex
graphs you can actually you know be very
you can actually build the graphs you
want as you want them but you can end up
a lot of people like desk because Matt
Rockland was very good at creating
little videos of the task actually
executing so you can look at this
directed graph you can see the task
excuse it goes kind of builds
understanding a little bit about what
parallelism might mean so you can
there's been a lot of people using it
x-ray is one of the first projects to
adopt ask second image has adopted desk
and you can basically use that to build
parallel runtime
here's a great blog post by jake von der
plas who talked about experimenting with
out of core data frames in python to do
openstreetmap interact with the
OpenStreetMap data set so the very few
lines of code you can basically build
very quick solutions I've been excited
about the distributed schedule for a
while and we've actually got Matt
Rockland just released it's still beta
this distributed library it's very
simple I like it because it's simple so
there's not a huge thank you not a huge
interface this is probably a good place
to end because I love everybody to go
look at distributed distribute it if
you're interested in multi-core if you
interested in spark if you like what
spark does for you take a look and see
just moves very early it's still new
you'll probably run into problems so you
know talk to us if you if you use it and
want to use it to see wow how it works
however it's very simple so it's making
progress and solidifying rapidly what it
does it lets you define a simple cluster
so the same kind of modeling of a center
driver and a bunch of workers and you
can set them all up with either d
cluster or individual ed center and
worker if you have to interface with
another scheduler and then what it does
it creates executors objects it's ad hoc
pythonic parallelism that understands
dass graphs so you can basically if you
just used ask you can kind of import the
distributed scheduler and just use it
that way or if you want to get into more
of the details you can look you little
distributed as a separate library and
start building executors and it follows
the concurrent futures API in Python 3
or equivalently the futures library
backported to python 27 with the
exception that it adds data locality so
instead of always returning results it
will return futures from from remote
systems so they can continue in the
graph you continue to build out future
computations so what it allows is a
great blog post here python on hadoop
without the JVM which is an awesome
thing if your data stored in HDFS and
you love Python and you're forced
currently to narrow through the PI
streaming interface you can basically
with distributed and pandas read and
distribute and process CSV files or
other files in HDFS very very easily and
it'll be even easier coming soon there's
just some slides showing them things you
can do okay so that's pretty much all
the time I have I have more slides here
on bouquet a number that I'll make
available but I wanted to basically
end by you know summarizing that Python
is going to continue to be a very easy
way to connect experts with data and
produce produce solutions rather than
futzing with details and that are they
at the heart of it that's the Zen of
data science is getting the attention
being the core ideas in the hands the
people that know what they're doing and
iterating quickly so thank you for your
time and maybe there's property for one
or two questions
no questions okay they're just getting
there just getting brave in the back
there
yeah Virgil em does not support general
C++ libraries very easily so Conda is a
general system environment capability it
used the idea of virtual em but it
allows your Python to be more than just
Python files to be HDFS and hdf5 and
anything the C++ we're like required
inning fortune required all that works
all those environment that great
environment capability now works easily
just as easily yeah yeah we work inside
docker doctors sort of a separate
concept of concept of virtual machines
or it's lighter weight than virtual
machines countess even lighter weight
than that it's a it's a file system
based approach and shared linking the
way shared linking works approach so it
works inside but what I've found is a
lot of people use docker when they could
just use Conda and get end up and be a
lot simpler a lot of simpler a lot less
file LS Lala's mess so we don't quite
have the budget of the docker folks who
advertise so no and also that's more
than that too is the I a lot of our
systems are ruled by the IT world by sis
administrators to understand data
science necessarily and so they're
persuaded by a different batch of things
and data site you know we wrote Conda
really to help data scientists
scientists experts so kind of make it
easier for them and try to really veer
it and use the language of IT
administrators to help them understand
how it helps them as part of the is part
of the challenge kind of a messaging
challenge great question anybody else we
have time right there
Oh awesome got a number of fan in the
audience I love number too so it's one
of my favorites yeah she said he really
enjoys working with number can you tell
us a little bit i'll just show you one
slide i love the new release of number
by the way i'm so excited it's getting
we're getting close to be able to get
towards one point oh we need jit classes
basically and you know so number is
basically ability to pump compile Python
code so you can write image processing
code in Python you know you wouldn't do
this before with numba why not hey it's
easy you can do it there's also a
vectorized function I would say you know
here's the want to make two things where
CUDA python is now open source so you
can use cuda pi f no little cuda it's
not necessarily and Cudas not easy
necessarily but it's a lot easier from
python than it is to experiment with
with CC i would say but there's some
interesting things a number that have
come out the recent release new GPU
target the HSA architecture supported
limited support for name two pools
simulator for debugging GPU functions
available you can choose to release the
Gila know python functions very easy to
do that ahead of time compilation so you
actually use numba the same way people
use scythe on to produce extension
modules but you can write this python
code you've written and it just produces
a shared module you can ship to somebody
isn't have number so that's that's
recent and improving it's still it's
still you know it may not work in every
case you may want it to but it's the
improvement are happening and vectorize
do you vectorize GPU and parallel
targets now open source so it's an on
disk caching of your code so you don't
have to compile every time if you warm
it up your disk may warm up with the
compiled code and then it's faster
loading next time so all right that's it
thanks everybody appreciate it
you